Richard Reeves in his new book argues
that the Modern Man and boy is
struggling across three domains in
education
and employment
and as fathers
me and Richard will be in conversation
for about 30 to 35 minutes
um if you have a question you can ask
your question by clicking on the ask
question button under the video screen
and then pressing send
and please get involved on social media
by using the hashtag iq2
the first question for you Richard is
why is the City of Kalamazoo in
Southwest Michigan so interesting for
policy wonks
uh I should say that Kalamazoo is also
interesting to Glenn Miller fans so
those who know that Glenn Miller will
know the famous song I've got a girl in
Kalamazoo so if you're if you've heard
the name my guess is unless you're a
policy wonk that's most likely that you
will have heard of it
um but it's it's interesting to policy
wonks because it's a city that has had
free college for all of its uh
graduating high school seniors so if you
graduate from the high school in that in
that City then you can go to college
pretty much anywhere in the state for
free full tuition paid
um and and it's also been very well
evaluated so it's a very generous free
college scheme but it's also been very
well evaluated to see what effect it
would have what effect would it have on
College completion in particular and
what the evaluators found was it had a
massive effect on female college
completion so uh the the young women in
Kalamazoo became about 50 percent more
likely to get a call at four-year
college degree which was a huge change
uh in terms of public policy terms
that's a massive impact but for men the
number was Zero had absolutely no impact
on the likelihood of uh of boys and then
young men from that uh City going on to
get a four-year college degree so the
equivalent of a ba uh three-year college
degree in the UK and that's a pretty
extraordinary fact and that led me to
look at a whole bunch of other
interventions that find similar results
where you'll see pretty strong effects
for girls or women
and negative effects or Zero Effect for
boys or young men and so in a way that's
one of the things that led me to write
this book because we know that there are
some issues say in education for for
boys and men but it's sort of rubbing
salt in the wounds if then many of the
interventions that are being tried to
improve education overall
are helping girls and women but not
helping boys and men
so when does this Gap in education start
between boys and girls and what are the
possible causes for it
uh it starts at the beginning basically
I mean you can't you can't really find
somebody in the education system
well
um that's a good question uh you said in
the terms when you think education
starts sure I don't know of any
particular good evidence for differences
in skills say among two-year-olds
um there are differences in Behavior
among two-year-olds so like two-year-old
boys are much more physically aggressive
for example than two-year-old girls and
have to be taught not to do that which
is kind of probably evidence that some
of that's natural but that may maybe
that's the subject we'll get on to Tom
um but uh essentially from the beginning
at least from when we start measuring it
right so as soon as we measure it when
they start school or they measure it
again uh you know say at the start of
secondary school and then again at the
end of gcses a levels Etc
um and essentially the Gap runs in favor
of girls uh every step of the way it
does get wider at certain points and
narrow other points so it seems to be a
little bit wider at the beginning maybe
Narrows a little bit
um up into the early teen years and then
it widens again quite dramatically
during the teen years and so it's pretty
wide by the time you get to the end of
secondary school yeah and what do you
think what are the possible causes for
this Gap
so I think there's a number of uh
possible speculation speculations here I
think I think the main ones are that on
average and maybe we should just preface
that almost everything I'm going to say
is on average so I don't have to say it
every time because that get boring and
the distribution is overlap can we just
keep can we take that as given right
sure maybe edit that in later
um but on average boys develop a little
bit more slowly they develop later than
girls uh and that's especially true in
adolescence because girls hit puberty
earlier and one of the things that does
that triggers the development of parts
of the brain uh especially the
prefrontal cortex which is that's the
bit of your brain that says do your
physics homework don't go to the party
that's the bit of your brain that says
you should study for these tests rather
than just turn up and hope for the best
it's the bit of your brain that says if
I don't do well in these exams I won't
go to college and then I'll struggle in
life so it's future orientation and that
bit of the brain is develops about a
year or two earlier in girls
and so if you have an education system
that rewards those sorts of behaviors
which we do then we should sort of be we
should be surprised if girls weren't
ahead the surprise is that they weren't
ahead all along and the reason they
weren't ahead all along is because of
sexism
it actually under conditions where girls
and women were actively discouraged from
pursuing education especially higher
education than the natural advantages
they had in the education system
couldn't be seen so it's paradoxical
that it took the women's movement to
expose the ways in which the education
system is structured in favor of girls
and women including in this timing
timing way the other two I'll just
mentioned briefly is one is that
teaching is becoming a more female
profession over time and there's some
evidence of having male teachers can be
particularly beneficial for boys and so
that could be a part of it too and then
the last is that the boys on average
tend to do better with more vocational
forms of learning than girls and and but
most of our spending on education still
goes on traditional education so things
like apprenticeships vocational you know
vocational training uh doesn't get the
same Investments and so that tends that
tends to Herb always a bit more
sure and is this education Gap
um true across the world or is it true
in certain countries
it's true uh in all advanced economies
so like one data point would be in every
oecd country so to the extent that
you're an economically Advanced enough
to be in the oecd then there are more
young women than young men with a
college degree uh in every oecd country
I think the last across I think the last
across the line might be Mexico but um
someone can fact check that for me in
real time
um but interestingly even outside the
oecd second number of striking number of
Middle East Middle Eastern countries and
so on you are seeing a gender gap in
favor of women in some levels
um but it's obviously not true in many
of the poorer parts of the world and so
the one of the difficulties with this
conversation is that the ways in which
women and girls are outpacing boys and
men are quite local so it's it is
typically in advanced economies that
we're mostly talking about and recent uh
this only happened in the last few
decades it's happened spectacularly
quickly but it's happened very recent
and so we wouldn't be having this
conversation 40 years ago and we
wouldn't be having it still in probably
half the countries in the world sure
what is redshirting
red shirting is a U.S term borrowed from
Athletics which is to delay entry to
school for a year or delay entry to a
secondary school for a year so you
basically uh enter whatever the school
year is a year older and it used to be
done mostly for athletic reasons so in
the US it was very often done and this
is particularly true for male Sports
um but just being bigger uh and stronger
uh was going to be to your advantage so
actually you know being 19 is helpful
when you're playing a contact sport
um then moving everything else equal you
could you could get and you've got a bit
more time to train but now there's now
uh it's been used as a term for academic
red shirting so that's that's the
decision to delay entry into school not
because you want your kid to be the best
football player or whatever uh or rugby
player but because you want them to do
better at math and better English and do
better in their exams and so that's
really now the main driver of of what
this quotes redshirting phenomenon sure
interesting
um in the book you argue of course that
um the differences between uh boys and
girls or men and women
um which explains the differences in
terms of Education
um
is at least partly because of biology so
what would you say to somebody that says
by insisting on the importance of
biology you are merely
um endorsing something that's been used
historically to oppress women
what mood I was in
so like so let's let's say I'm in a
conciliatory mood and I'm at a public
event you know so I I'm going to say I
totally understand where you're coming
from
that is absolutely no
Etc the truth is I'd say are you crazy
like like if I'm being candid about it
yeah it's just you and me it's just you
and me right so I can only see you I can
only see you yes yeah
like no nobody out there in the real
world thinks that there aren't some
biological differences that have some
consequences for things like education
no one who's raised boys or been a boy
or met a boy things that there aren't
some of these differences the real
debate is not not whether there are
differences it's like how big they are
in what domains and how much they matter
that's that's the real that's the real
debate and actually
um the problem with the whole debate
about male and female brains is this
kind of focus on adults by which time
most of the differences have actually
washed out by the time you get to your
mid-20s and going forward what that
disguises is the biggest difference is
in the timing of brain development which
we just discuss which does have
significant implications for Education
right so even if you don't even if we
can even if you don't think there's much
difference in male and female brains
among 28 year olds which there isn't
much difference
um and not very consequential sure that
doesn't mean it's true for 14 or 15 year
olds and there there's no disagreement
among neuroscientists at all the
question is how far it overlaps so I'd
say and the last thing I'll say on this
is the thing I find quite frustrating
about this debate is
acknowledging that nature has a role
doesn't make culture less important it
makes it more important because culture
is what determines how and whether and
when we express some of these natural
differences so to acknowledge nature is
not to deny culture it is to elevate
culture
um so in that sense it's not it's a
completely false binary yeah and do you
think the fact is that explain why
boys are struggling and schools relative
to girls
also explains why men are struggling
an employment relative to women or are
they or is it something different going
on it's mostly something different so to
the extent the boys who struggle in
education
are going to find it harder in the labor
market and especially now so so that
that's obviously that's a factor but the
main thing that's that's hit male
employment and male wages uh has been
external shocks to the economy so for
free trade globalization and more
automation right and that's nothing to
do with the rise of women in the labor
market and nothing to do with brain
development and not directly anything to
do the education system
Etc the extent that we now need to
prepare man for this new world but but
actually it's just what's happened is
the traditionally male jobs have just
been hit hard by industrialization and
free trade that's the fact and the
question then is how how quickly can men
adapt to the new world and so I think
that it's very important to realize that
things can happen at the same time
without necessarily being the cause of
the other so for example the rise of
women in the labor market has happened
at the same time that men have been hit
in the labor market but it's not but
it's not because women have risen that
men have fallen other things have
happened at the same time and in
particular de-industrialization
sure
um and do you think the struggles of men
in in the labor system
is one of the most important factors
that explain
um populism
I think that the the real difficulties
that many men are having right and
especially I think it's important not to
say this is not all men like this is not
typically the man at the top who are
actually one of those measures doing
pretty well working class men uh let's
use that term broadly uh the real
problems that they are having
uh if unaddressed or in some cases even
unacknowledged create fertile ground for
populist movements to the extent that
populism uh gets its fuel from grievance
um gets its fuel from reaction the
extent is reactionary then I think the
unaddressed male problems are really
they are just great fuel for the
populist fire and I think we've seen
that I think we've seen like
particularly among young britons for
example quite a big gender gap on brexit
um there's a huge gender gap over here
in the US from Donald Trump's Victory
um the rise at the right in East Germany
is strongly related to what's happening
to a lot of East German men and so I
think that the gender Dimension to
populism is a strong one and isn't isn't
talked about enough that we know about
class and of course that's probably even
more important but but I think this this
gender element uh is huge but I don't
think it has to be I think that what's
happened is because we haven't addressed
the problems Square on in the mainstream
that's created space for more dictionary
populists to to sort of pick up on that
because they're you know if you have
real problems that responsible people
don't address then irresponsible people
are going to exploit them that's a
that's a fact of human history I think
uh and if we're seeing that playing out
in this space now yeah but why do you
think the um Progressive left
um view this topic as a zero-sum game
um so they would say that focus in on
the unique struggles of boys and men
um potentially
um distracts us from
um being feminist why why do they see it
in such terms
I think that again in a generous mood
I would say that it's because it's
happened so fast and it's happened so
unbelievably quickly the UN updating
your priors
that quickly uh it's just really hard I
mean the cause of gender equality has
basically been synonymous with the cause
of women and girls for I don't know
let's say 10 000 years and has only
ceased to be so for let's say 40 30 40
years so we're talking about the blink
of an eye
um and and there are many remaining
challenges for women and girls and so I
just think it's really hard
to catch up with such a dramatic uh
social change I mean when you have a
situation where we've already talked
about the education gaps but you know 40
of British households now have a female
Breadwinner and that's just that's just
I I don't know what the number was 40
years ago but but it's probably probably
quadruple it's certainly just like it's
just a different it's a different world
even to the world I grew up in you know
only in my early 50s so this is just an
extraordinarily rapid change yeah and
and I think there's a sense that there's
only so much political Capital to go
around there's only so much money to go
around right if we spend this on boys
then it means we're going to spend less
of it on goals women but what I would
say is that in the long run when boys
and men are struggling that tends to end
up not helping women either sure of
course of course yeah so we've spoken
about
um what the progressive left get wrong
about the unique struggles faced by boys
and men what would you say the
conservative right or do they get wrong
on this issue
well it's a couple of things one is we
talked a bit about biology and we've
just had a discussion where like there
are some biological differences like
which is like a which is outside of like
some circles were like well duh and but
the right will sometimes then over over
emphasize those and so there's some as a
tendency I think to explain gender
inequalities too quickly by by result of
biological explanation that's because an
old story uh and so there's a lot of
nuance there but I'd say the biggest
thing is probably what um David Willits
once described as a tendency among
conservatives towards bring backery
which is a great phrase bring backery
yeah another thing I don't think I
managed to get that into the book that
was
um uh from his book about you know
generational inequality
um from a few from quite a few years
back now and what he means about is like
conservatives like we need to bring back
X we need to bring back the traditional
family bring back traditional
manufacturing jobs and bring back the
whatever it is right bring back X and I
think that when it comes to this issue
too often what conservatives will do is
to suggest that we can bring back the
traditional family and we can't
that's in the rear view mirror now the
women's movement has successfully
created a world in which women have much
more economic independence which is a
glorious wonderful thing arguably the
biggest human you know the biggest
Liberation in human history and on some
measures but that means you can't you
can't put Humpty back together again you
can't you can't rebuild family on the
basis of women's economic dependency on
men that world has gone and so the
trouble is that if you just talk about
traditional families traditional jobs
manufacturing Etc what you're really
doing is you're just holding out false
hope and that doesn't help men adapt
what we actually need to do is help man
adapt to the world as it is we're all in
the world as it was and conservatives
almost always fail to do that sure
um what what does
um Hill mean
h-e-a-l what is what does that mean
yes it's an acronym uh you know you need
a good acronym as everyone knows but
it's a it's uh it can't get anywhere
especially especially in policy circles
without an acronym and this one is like
the mirror image of stem so most people
heard a stem yeah science technology
engineering and math interesting well
most people don't know is that it wasn't
originally stem when Judith Ramirez went
to National Institutes of Health it was
actually Smet
sm-eat and she said oh I don't like the
sound of that I'm going to change it so
she changed it to stem and honestly the
rest is history
um we had stem caucuses has been a huge
push to get women women especially into
stem jobs pretty you know pretty
successfully
um heal is the opposite of that so it's
health education Administration and
literacy literacy skills as opposed to
math skills as in as you get in um in
stem and those jobs if we talk about
jobs account for a huge and growing part
of the economy I mean a growing needs
for people in those sorts of jobs
obviously for teachers but also for
healthcare workers social care workers
people whose jobs are more on the
administrative side rather than perhaps
the machine side more a bit more
relational
Etc and requiring all kinds of literacy
skills like how many you can go back you
can go back in time and find jobs we
didn't really have even to talk to
somebody very much during the course of
the day and those were very often male
jobs but that's much less true now and
so those skills those so-called soft
skills are becoming more important the
labor market and that's where the jobs
are coming from too yeah so um how
precisely can we get boys into those
jobs
Circle
yeah boys I'm glad you added that and so
it's a bit of a vicious circle because
as those professions either remain or in
some cases become more gender segregated
become more female in orientation it's
harder to persuade people like my own
son actually works in early years child
care but but that's like it's it's very
hard to find male child care workers I'm
looking at the numbers for the UK
recently there are almost no male child
care workers in the UK in fact they
couldn't find a single one in the whole
of Northern Ireland not one
um it's like literally literally none
and very few anywhere else and so and so
it's very hard then to persuade men to
go into it so you have to reduce the
stigma but the only way to do that is
there's obviously any good role models
we need male nurses and social workers
and teachers and psychologists going
into schools and Outreach programs just
as we've done for women into stem we've
worked really hard
to persuade girls that stem careers are
for them we need exactly the same Zeal
to persuade boys and men that those
professions that heal professions are
for them but I also think we probably
need some more aggressive action like
some scholarships specifically aimed
that meant to go into those professions
just as we've done for women into stem
um
um in terms of because many young men
and boys
um will see those professions as
emasculating
um so how can we get rid of that stigma
yeah well as I said I to some extent
what I think we we need some blunt
policy tools to try and increase male
representation so there's a great line
like which includes scholarships
subsidies let's you know bribes you know
a lot of money spent on it and so on to
try and just move and get more men into
them right so initially I think we're
just gonna have to like throw some money
at that issue to get more men in then
it'll then then the stigma will lessen
just because there are more men men
doing it but there's a great a great
phrase the women's movement is you have
to see it to be it sure and so I just
think how we present Role Models around
that is hugely important
um and so just think about popular
culture think about the ways in which we
depict those roles actually you know
advertising and TV is actually more
gender stereotypical about professions
even than the real world is and I think
the last thing I'll say is that what we
don't want to do is signal that these
jobs are that are somehow make them seem
more masculine they really are or more
feminine they really are we'll just be
pretty straightforward about it like
nursing nursing is a good career
um you know reasonably you know secure
Etc we don't have to sort of go
overboard and sort of making it somehow
seem Macho to be a nurse we just need to
make it seem not not as you said not
effeminate to be a nurse and so how we
talk about it's usually important sure
why do we need more black men in
particular to be teachers
well we need more men period yeah uh and
I think that's important um but we need
more black men because there is very
strong evidence that for black boys in
particular having a black male teacher
has some really positive effects I would
say it's probably true for Hispanic boys
as well in in the uh in the US at least
yeah um and there are even fewer
Hispanic male teachers actually lots
more Hispanic female teachers not many
more Hispanic male teachers
um and so I do think a kind of if we if
we think about gender and race
you know you have you have to see it to
be it and in particular because black
boys
uh are and this is this is a big
difference in the US and the UK actually
you know black boys are the ones who are
pretty much at the bottom of all of
these distributions in terms of
Education they are the ones who are
struggling most in education and the
gender gap is huge so already for every
for every one college degree a black man
gets two black women get a college
degree and so that you know so already
at two to one for black men and black
women so uh the gender gaps are much
bigger there and so we need a concerted
focus on black boys and men in
particular in the UK the story is more
strongly one of class and where you see
much more kind of class class really
plays in much more strongly yeah
um with that in mind how would you
respond to the claim made by many people
that espouse what's known as
intersectionality
um which is that
um black women in particular
um face the most struggles in society
because what you seem to be arguing is
that it's actually black men and black
boys other than black women and black
girls uh how would you respond to that
uh well first of all I'd just get out
some charts and some data I've already
alluded some of them so well yeah yeah
if you're you're not looking at the same
data as I am I mean yeah you know yeah
black black women in the US are more
upwardly mobile out of the bottom out of
the bottom out of poverty than any other
group
um certainly than black men are the
least
um you know black women in the
breadwinner in most households I've
already mentioned some of the education
actually among Young Americans there are
slightly more young black women with a
postgraduate degree than young white men
with a postgraduate degree and so
there's been this extraordinary now it's
not to suggest that it's job done for
black women but on most the dimensions
you care to look at you will find that
black men black boys and men
are doing significantly worse on a lot
of the measures we might care about than
black girls and women that's to me
that's that is intersectionality applied
properly because what it does is it said
you can't assume that the the position
of one group over another is somehow
fixed for all time right so if you if
you don't assume why Always above black
male always above female straight always
above gay
Etc because that will vary right it will
vary over time as to what that means now
as a general proposition we know that
those things are kind of mostly true but
then scramble it up and then add class
right scramble it up and what
intersectionality does is it scrambles
those categories and allows you to look
with more Precision than particular
groups okay yeah great great
um
in terms of being Fathers as well
can you envisage a future in which the
stay at home Dad
um becomes as normalized as normalized
as the state of mom
I'll be honest and say it's hard to
envisage it right now
but I think it's it's the the direction
we should be traveling in
the only thing it's one of the reasons
why why is why is it why is it the
direction we should be traveling in
um because of the evidence that fathers
actually matter as much to their kids
welfare and well-being as mothers and in
some ways and in some slightly different
and complementary ways again on average
um and also because like I've I've I
tend to write about this and do I make
this mistake I think in the book too of
just looking at it through the lens of
kids right what matters to kids right so
father I just did it then fathers matter
to kids but also being a parent being an
Engaged parent is massively important to
the identity and purpose and meaning of
people's lives and so if you deny that
to anybody mother's father then then
that's a huge loss and so I now think
it's actually important to think about
this from the point of view of men and
so I just think as a signal also to the
Next Generation the only caveat I'll add
to that is I'm reasonably convinced by
the evidence that dads really seem to
come into their own in adolescence it's
not that they don't matter up until that
point but they seem to have particular
value to add for teenagers
uh and so if anything it might go
slightly the other way for really young
kids so like just to say it much more
bluntly than I would kind of in the book
but it's like all right it's like
one-year-olds might be with mum but like
12 year olds should probably be with Dad
well it seems to be the um once you get
to teenage year your teenage years
you're sort of really pushing at the you
know you're pushing at the envelope
you're trying to you're taking more
risks you're going out in the world Etc
and it looks as if again on whereas when
you're very young it's more about
nurturing right so when you're really
young you just need to write you need
nurture or need to be kept like you
don't need you only need to know like
two people like One whatever you're not
out there making Networks you're not
you're not you're not partying
um but as you get into teenage years
especially more deeply into adolescence
you're basically learning how to grow
into the world and take risks
um and it looks as if uh fathers have
some something of a competitive
Advantage when it comes to helping their
kids learn how to to manage risk get out
there in the world learn how to be more
independent and so it you know so it
looks as if dads might be a little bit
better at helping
again I'll simplify horribly but it's
like if mums are really good at like
keeping the kids safe in the nest dads
are pretty good at helping them to
successfully get out of the nest sure
again these are averages but and so what
that means is that you know parental
leave should be available to both but it
should be available throughout childhood
there's a bit of an early years
determinism sometimes like it's game
over by five we're learning much more
that adolescence is just as important as
the early years but it's really
neglected in public policy and I think
sometimes it's neglected by parents too
foreign